my name is NaN Chanda I'm director of
publications and they sent
elation and we are very pleased to have
with us in our studio garret events the
former foreign mr. Australia and the
president of the International Crisis
Group and now he is the co-chair of
international Commission for nuclear
non-proliferation and disarmament which
was set up with the support from
Australian and Japanese government and
they have just put out this report on
the tasks ahead
Gareth welcome nice to be here know him
so the fact that United States and
Russia both of them have nine thousand
and thirteen thousand nuclear weapons
after they have decided to cut back some
that kind of intrigues me as to why on
earth to do they need that many weapon
well don't need anything like those
number of weapons I mean in the Cold War
years in the early years was even worse
there was about seventy thousand nuclear
warheads overwhelmingly held between
those two countries very few by the
other nuclear-armed States in the
immediate term post Cold War years that
was dramatically reduced but the trouble
is for the last ten years or more we've
just been sleepwalking on this issue the
significance of President Obama's Advent
to the administration his commitment to
nuclear disarmament and his embrace of
President Medvedev in moving at least
the game forward again is that it now
opens the window to make further further
significant reductions in the future we
haven't achieved enormous amount by the
US Russia recently negotiated agreement
that's taken a few hundred strategically
deployed weapons back into storage but
they haven't been destroyed you're right
in saying that the two countries between
them have 22,000 weapons 95 percent of
the current world stockpile
and if we're going to be serious about
disarmament we of course have to
dramatically reduce that I think the
immediate objective should just be to
get the numbers down to much lower
levels than that but without in any way
prejudicing the security interests even
very generously conceived of the two
countries
what we're proposing in our Commission
report is that over the next 15 years we
reduce that that stockpile down to about
2,000 weapons in total with Russia in
the United States having 500 each all
the other countries no more than a
thousand between them that's still an
awful lot of weapons and capable of
destroying that world quite a few times
over and far more than anyone would
rationally need but I think it's an
indication of the magnitude of the task
just how far we got to go to get to more
reasonable limits but one could ask why
do you need to come back from weapons
because they have been lying there in
silos they have not caused any harm so
what's the what's the reason for you to
get so agitated and then people to
organize this to cut back on nuclear
weapons what's the harm in keeping them
because it's just a matter of sheer dumb
luck it's not a matter of the inherent
stability of the system or brilliant
political leadership or anything else
that those weapons have not been used
for the last 65 years in example luck
I'll give you plenty of examples about
what's happened during the Cold War
years that we're only now beginning to
recognize as more and more information
comes to light there are multiple
occasions during the Cold War years when
we came extraordinarily close to
catastrophe through a combination of
human error or machine error or
decisions made under operational stress
let me just give you two examples one
was when Senator Chuck Percy years ago
in the middle of the Cold War went to
that secret Mountain a US senator that's
senator Chuck Percy I went on a routine
sort of inspection visit to the North
American command system for
NORAD buried away in a mountain in the
u.s. Midwest and the technicians put a
demonstration tape in the system to show
him what it would look like on the
screens if there was in fact an Russian
or Soviet nuclear strike on the United
States unfortunately I put it in the
wrong machine well they pressed the
wrong button
and so all of a sudden the screens
around the wall and lit up with the
information that 200 ICBMs were on their
way to attack America and it took about
3540 minutes to unravel the situation
people too real
as what had happened and D alert the
system and breathing sighs of relief all
around that's one example before the
president does all come after well we
still have I mean the crazy thing is is
this to this day twenty years after the
end of the Cold War we still have the
President of Russia and the prison of
the United States carrying around these
electronic footballs to give them with
coded with electronic command
information and it's an under the
present alert system they have between
12 and 18 minutes of a window in which
to respond to information or
misinformation about an incoming nuclear
attacks so this is let me just give you
another example
I'm during the Cold War years the Cuban
Missile Crisis in the early 60s we now
know that it wasn't just a matter of
missiles on their way to Cuba in the
Russian ship about which all the
blockade fuss was we now know there were
actually nuclear weapons in Cuba on
Cuban soil we also know that they're on
Russian Soviet submarines in the
surrounding waters one extraordinary
story has just come to light in recent
years that's as part of the naval
blockade American ships warships were
dropping depth charges periodically just
to let Russian submarines in the region
know who was there and who was boss not
intending to hurt them but one such
depth charge knocked out the
communication system with Moscow of one
of these Soviet submarines that led to
total panic and disarray on the
submarine as to what they do because
they were completely blind and deaf as
to what was going on the commander
decided that it was obviously a wartime
situation and he wanted to press the
button to fire his nuclear torpedo it he
was physically restrained by his senior
crew members who said no this is almost
certainly just an accident for God's
sake we don't want to start World War 3
it was as close as that now of course
nowadays it's not just it's not just the
supposedly super sophisticated command
and control systems of Russia and the
United States we're talking about we've
got other players in the game have got
India and Pakistan and frankly their
command and control systems are not
nearly as sophisticated as those that
have shown themselves so vulnerable
dumb luck that held up the cold warriors
yeah may not do so and absolutely not in
many ways the threat situation is now
worse than it was during the cold war
years because you really only have the
two major players with nuclear weapons
now we've got others in the game yeah we
have now a Pakistan India Israel plus
the original North Korea and North Korea
with a small handful of nuclear
explosive device maybe possibly yeah
maybe around that's the big policy yes
let's talk about these newcomers because
in 1995 NPT non-proliferation treaty
review Commission held was held since
then we have now two new declared powers
understand and India and North Korea has
also exploded a bomb so the
non-proliferation treaty is really under
threat
it has it has held so far until 1995 and
now it is kind of well it's still
holding together much better than was
anticipated at the start 40 years ago
was anticipated by now that we would
have 30 or 40 nuclear powers but the
taboo that is constituted by that treaty
has been fantastically important in
giving countries confidence that others
wouldn't break out but the vulnerability
the weakness of the treaty is becoming
really rather apparent we it was
possible for a number of countries to
develop secret programs some of which
were abandoned like Libya's some of
which were dealt with in other ways like
Syria's they were programs that operated
in secret without the International
Atomic Energy Agency which is the
guardian of the non-proliferation treaty
being aware of what was going on and to
the extent that have had suspicions that
something was going on outside the civil
power reactors it didn't have the power
or the authority to do the necessary
investigations and monitoring it's that
sort of thing that we do have to improve
now if we're going to ensure that
they're not further breakouts I don't
think we should be in despair about the
treaty the india-pakistan was always an
accident waiting to happen neither of
them had signed on to the treaty they
had always indicated it was a
possibility that they would not observe
this discipline it's a real worry that
North Korea
because it has broken away because it
was a member of the treaty and it would
be a real worry if Iran were to walk
away from the treaty because it's been a
member all these years and has committed
itself you know quite overtly to not
acquiring nuclear weapons I don't think
we should give up on Iran I don't think
we should make the assumption my
commission does not make the assumption
that Iran is hell-bent on becoming a
nuclear weapons pair but clearly it's a
very fragile situation at the moment the
both North Korea and Iran seems to be
guided by the leaf that unless you have
a nuclear weapon nobody takes it
seriously and then you have it sort of
bargaining power not necessarily
deterrence parties bargaining power with
the nukes is that the question I think
that's right to North Korea and better
design their bargaining power so to the
extent that the rest of the world and
the region gives it security guarantees
and give it some economic benefits I
still think there's a chance that
they'll put their nuclear weapons back
in the box and denuclearize the
peninsula the case of Iran I don't think
at all we should assume that Iran has
made that calculation Iran knows that if
it were to acquire even just one or two
weapons of the kind that North Korea has
done that would be seen by Israel its
immediate neighbor as a real existential
threat and the Iranians are much more
concerned about the military
consequences of that just where's the
North Koreans I think thought that if
they acquired some weapons it was not a
matter of them exposing themselves to
attack it was a matter of preventing
attack I think the Iranians know that
they're in a very much more vulnerable
position I think they also know the
Iranians that if they do cross this big
red line and actually weaponized as
distinct from having the the breakout
capability if they do actually weaponize
I think the Iranians also know that
they'll lose any kind of residual
support from both Russia and China and
they'll be in a very very vulnerable
position as a result in the Security
Council very very serious sanctions can
be expected to follow if not military
consequences
I think the Iranians also know
that if they do acquire nuclear weapons
there are other countries in the region
like the Egyptians possibly the Saudis
possibly the Syrians possibly the Turks
who will find it very very difficult to
resist getting into the nuclear weapons
game that's the real preparation risk
whereas in Northeast Asia because South
Korea because Japan potential
adversaries of North Korea because they
had the protection of the US nuclear
umbrella and the u.s. extended
deterrence guarantee there's always been
a very very strong discipline against
proliferation in North East Asia we
don't have those same dynamics operating
in the Middle East but the good news
about that is that that is quite likely
I believe to inhibit Iran from actually
taking this step I mean Iran is doing an
awful lot of chest-beating at the moment
Iran is absolutely obsessed with issues
of national pride and the way in which
was ignored by the West during the
iran-iraq war and I'm sure Iran wants to
have a visible technical breakout
capability but that's not the same thing
as to say that it's not determined to
have weapons so do you get the sense you
have been talking to leaders all over
the world especially after the report
came out do you get the sense that the
world is now coming to accept that they
can leave with a breakout capability of
Iran as long as it doesn't actually
assemble a weapon and if that message is
being convicted on that you can actually
have all the capability but don't make
it yeah I think I think that message is
now starting to get through from both
the Europeans and the Americans the
trouble is it's been too long coming the
trouble was back this this situation was
really resolved abou back in 2003 when
Iran had very very minimal centrifuge
capability that's to say the capability
of making enriched uranium the
ingredient for a bomb very very limited
capability it suspended that as a result
of maybe post Iraq war pressures and so
on and it made it clear that it was
willing to continue that suspension
provided that it's right to serve
acknowledged was acknowledged to to
produce a real imited amount of enriched
enriched uranium the West however the
rest of the wheel said no no no no
you've got or you've got a reverse
course you've got to go back to zero in
Iran not totally unreasonably said well
it's our right under the
non-proliferation treaty to do anything
that's peaceful in character including
making this stuff and as long as we
don't actually weaponize or make this
stuff up to weapons-grade we're fully
entitled to do it so we had a standoff
the Iranian pride was at stake and it
wasn't very well negotiated now I think
we've moved beyond that point of course
in an ideal world the Iranians would
renounce enrichment capability they
would internationalize that they would
just have nuclear energy facilities
without the bomb starter kits that go
with it
you know the enrichment process in
richmond' facility but we're not in an
ideal world we're past that point and I
think where we're heading is to a kind
of standoff where the Iranians do have
breakout capability and maybe the
capacity within 12 months or so to
acquire weapons if they made that
decision and the rest of the world is
prepared to live with that provider the
Iranians accept very intrusive
monitoring and inspections and
verification to ensure that people have
a rough idea that if they do move across
that line we'll we'll know about it I
think that's the kind of solution we're
all now groping in a way toward but if
indeed is motivated by the question of
national honor and prestige for them now
to stop and say okay we allow you to
inspect climb down for them well I've
achieved an awful lot in terms that
ignored Security Council resolutions
they have ignored ia resolutions they've
shown their absolute determination to
stare the rest of the world down to
thumb their nose there to demonstrate
they had a right to enrich them and
that's what the argument is really all
being about and if they have an
acknowledged unequivocal right to enrich
uranium they've had a very big win
and I think it's just a matter of
recognizing that and finding a way of
expressing this there's a very
interesting development in the last few
months last October I'd think the West
in a very creative with Russia in a very
creative new initiative offered to Iran
that just as a sort of a temporary
measure a cooling-off measure we would
accept that they they had a right to
have done what they did was enriched
uranium we would take it from them
process it and put it into fuel rods in
a form that could be used in Iran's own
research reactors and give it straight
back to them the advantage of this is
that had bought time for everybody the
advantage for Iran was that it
recognized that they had a right to
enrich nobody was challenging that the
advantage for the west of course was
this great stock of enriched uranium low
enriched uranium that was there at the
moment has taken out of play as possible
weapons material the very very
interesting thing is that a million
Nejad actually wanted to accept this
emitting a jar the guy who runs around
the world saying crazy things and really
upping the ante who all the time
recently talking to mcgaubey about you
know doing everything possible to
irritate and rage meeting that Iran was
prepared to accept it who made it
impossible for him to accept now the
good guys miss AVI the internal
Democrats that we're all applauding in
the internal reactions of the last year
who said to a meeting Assad you're
selling out the national interest so
this is a very very holiday our Fleck
it's a very very you know and we we
should not make any assumptions that
there is somewhere in the core of the
Iranian polity a group of people who
want to move away completely from a
nuclear program the point is on all
available evidence on all my
conversations with many many Iranians as
well as others over the years I'm sure
that this is a national pride thing but
I don't think that pride goes I think
it's a miss reading of the situation I
say the pride demands actual weapons the
pride demands the demonstration of
technological prowess the pride demands
staring down the Western attempt to deny
them that that capability so with a bit
of luck we'll be able to manage this but
it's going to take very cool here
over the next few minutes it's a
variation that has been built up now is
kind of the stick and the carrot already
offered i think the sanctions moved by
the united states is entirely defensible
because you can't have people thumbing
their nose at Security Council
resolution you can't have States
thumbing their nose at International
Atomic Energy Agency resolution saying
you've got explain better this evidence
we have that in the past you've engaged
in a weapons research program you can't
I mean the credibility of a rule-based
international system globalized current
world depends on on institutions not
being dealt with in that way and I think
the Russians are very much understand
that I think the Chinese actually
understand that too and while they don't
want to have such a rough sanctions set
of disciplines imposed on Iran that it
will somehow operate to close the door
on negotiations I think they acknowledge
that this can't go on addressed I mean
China is is a country that's very
concerned to ensure the continued
credibility in particular the Security
Council and this is part of the dynamic
it's works I mean the trick with Iran in
the months ahead will be to make clear
that the sanctions by the sanctions
route in the Security Council that the
world can't tolerate the way in which
the Iranians have been playing the game
so far but at the same time keep that
door open for negotiations on the basis
that we've been talking about and it is
simply President Obama hosted this
summit meeting in Washington regarding a
nuclear security now apart from
countries like Iran North Korea the non
governmental entities getting their hand
on nuke how real that threat is it's a
serious risk not as serious as it was in
the immediate post Cold War years when a
huge amount of effort was put in by
senators Nunn and Luger in the in the
United States with a lot of money being
invested a lot of cooperative support
from Russia and the former Soviet Union
countries to reduce that risk in the
world's most vulnerable area as it was
but there's still residual areas of
there were still research reactors all
over the world working on the basis of
highly enriched uranium which is bomb
equivalent interior in a way that's not
not properly secured with anything like
the barbed wire fences or so many of
these reactors are on university
campuses they may well be one here and
Yael for I need to check but I mean
there's this sort of stuff everywhere
and this is very vulnerable to to theft
or diversion I think that is what kind
of do it that's still a little bit of
fissile material what can they do with
that well had comparatively small amount
can be engineered into Hiroshima scale
sized bomb and we know the damage that
can be done you don't need you know in
engineering plants with hundreds of
people you need maybe a team of 15 or 20
people and as such is very vulnerable to
security penetration any such terrorist
exercise of this kind which would maybe
why it hasn't happened so far but the
basic the basic engineering is not it's
not produce the kind of device that
could be you don't have to drop it from
airplane either you could put it in the
back of a white van or you know small
boat driven into New York Harbor or
something and another major major major
nuclear explosion on our hands so the
threat is real it wasn't hiked by
President Obama
it wasn't hiked by all those countries
who assembled recently in Washington and
I think what is interesting is that
there's been a huge measure of agreement
about the need to address this problem
of loose nuclear weapons loose nuclear
material that's one of the few issues on
this very large non-proliferation and
disarmament agenda on which we can
unequivocally I think record a tick
because there there is buy-in to this
but on the basic issue of a really
serious commitment by all the present
nuclear-armed state to disarmament on
the issue of a willingness to actually
strengthen the non-proliferation regime
there are still divisions and I think
the important thing for the period I
heard the important thing for the big
may non-proliferation treaty review
conference which is looking at all these
issues the important thing is that we
adopt a genuinely globalized perspective
on this it's not as
though disarmament is a South agenda
it's not as though non-proliferation as
a north a gender issue the truth is both
disarmament and non-proliferation is
that everybody's interest their global
agendas the universal agendas and we
have to get that mindset going give us
one of the main agenda item for the
non-proliferation review well I think
there's five I mean one there has to be
a strong statement on disarm at a really
strong commitment by all the weapons
States that they've got an unequivocal
commitment however long it takes to get
to a zero weapon free world to give away
the weapons that's not going to be easy
to give in fact that was the original
intention up not NPT well it was a
two-fold bargain and the weapons states
had to while their right to hang on to
their weapons for the time being was
acknowledged they had to commit to get
really know what we were saying is now
for this review conference there has to
be a much clearer articulation and more
believable articulation of that
commitment by France and all these other
countries that are maybe not so clear
number two there has to be agreement on
strengthening the non-proliferation
regime in the ways that we mentioned
particularly so far as as inspection
monitoring and bitter ability to detect
these breakout situations three we have
to find a way forward on the question of
a Middle East nuclear weapons or weapons
of mass destruction free zone which has
been hanging around since 95 as an issue
about which the non-aligned movement the
South countries are very passionate that
there's got to be forward movement we're
not going to see such a zone negotiate
at anytime soon I mean Israel is not
going to be in that business so long as
they got worries about Iran at least but
if we can make credible steps forward
that's important that's but finding
words to accommodate these different
perspectives it's going to be very very
tricky a fourth issue relates to
peaceful uses of nuclear energy that's
fine there's plenty of agreement in
principle or about supporting that new
developments new countries going down
that path but finding a way of achieving
this that doesn't make us vulnerable by
new countries acquiring these enrichment
facilities or reprocessing facilities
which really the precursors for weapon
making capability if we can just get to
the stage where the necessary enrichment
manufacturing is done on an
internationalized basis on a regional
basis on some sort of international fuel
bank basis that would be terrific but
that's a that's a controversial issue
because countries say well why should we
be discriminated in if we want to in the
future do what a lot of countries are
now doing themselves so there's that
issue and the final issue is nuclear
security I'm in agreement on issues
about counterterrorism and ensuring non
today I don't think that will be
controversial because the Obama summit
has has cleared the way but when you
look at the the complexity each one of
those issue areas I mean reaching
reaching agreements not going to be easy
but the atmosphere is better than five
years ago I mean then we were in the
immediate aftermath of the Iraq war Bush
administration was a very different
kettle of fish on these issues than the
Obama administration so with a bit of
luck that we can even with the
administration change how do you see the
prospect of the Senate ratifying the
comprehensive test-ban treaty that was
signed by the US but never ratified well
there are many important issues that are
out there which are going to be
necessary to continue the momentum it's
not just a matter of getting agreement
at this non-proliferation treaty review
conference it is a matter of ensuring
that the us-russia treaty that we've
talked about is in fact ratified by the
US Senate which needs 67 votes which
does mean Republicans joining to support
this which is going to be very difficult
in the present political environment so
there's a question mark about that but
it's fantastically important because
without this treaty being bedded down
we've got no chance of moving to the
next round and the next round and the
next round of deep reductions that we
need to really get that Arsenal down
similarly with the Comprehensive Test
Ban Treaty at the moment that's not
formally in force there is a worldwide
voluntary moratorium against testing
which everybody has agreed to but there
are still nine countries that have to
sign and ratify the treaty before it
comes into force the u.s. is one of them
President Obama made a very strong
commitment last year to to crash through
that barrier he's tried but
again the Senate is creating real
difficulties the numbers are just not
there
if so it's a very the US Senate ratifies
then you think the other eight will fall
in line I certainly think the China will
fall in line
I believe that India will fall in line I
think that in turn will place a lot of
pressure on Pakistan to follow suit then
it becomes the Middle East group we've
got to get Egypt which is a bit
cantankerous on these issues Israel but
other countries as well
Iran in particular I mean the rounds got
to got to clearly do this and that's
going to be very tricky but I think the
truth of the matter is if the u.s. does
does actually break this this barrier
it's very difficult because the US are
not very good at ratifying treaties it
took 40 years to ratify the Genocide
Convention for unison and then look at
what happened on D on the Kyoto Protocol
the law of the sea is not ratify the
issue after issue after issue then the
u.s. is not very good at adopting a
global perspective on these issues but I
think the important thing is that we
have with this current administration
without being partisan about it for the
first time in a very long time the US
administration which is genuinely at the
top passionately committed to ultimately
achieving a nuclear weapons-free world
and if the the need now internationally
is to sustain that meant and 2010 is
really a critical watershed year in our
report we talked about the short-term
period being to 2012 after traveling to
nearly 25 countries in the last three or
four months since our report was
released I think actually we don't have
until 2012 to get to the short term
benchmarks I think this year 2010 is
really critical and the most critical
things that have a successful outcome of
the non-proliferation treaty review
conference and to have a that
ratification of the us-russian treaty a
lot of other issues as well and of
course to keep the situations in Korea
and in Iran contained and hopefully
resolved if we can
get through the year with those
achievements I think we can sustain the
momentum towards the nuclear
weapons-free world if we go backwards on
those issues this year I think there's
every horrible chance we'll move back
into the sleepwalk that the world has
been in for over a decade and which is a
very dangerous place to be because as we
began by saying the risks that are out
there the combination the existing
weapons possible misuse new countries
coming into the game terrorist non-state
actors and the risks associated with
peaceful uses of nuclear energy if new
countries acquire these enrichment and
other facility when you add all those
risks together plus the risk of
sophisticated cyber warfare
misinformation we just can't continue
with the status quo and my my worry is
and my Commission's where I use that
unless we we make some big steps forward
this year in the way we've described we
are going to be looking at a very very
difficult period a hidden let's hope we
don't get there while Gareth Evans thank
you very much for speaking with us thank
you no appreciate